can i play offline you cannot there are
no NPCs you don't want it to be grief II
but we want to have some drama there a
lot people we're wondering you know
that's obviously in an online your Iron
Man how is that going to be a comp deal
there okay other than we love mods we
will not be able to do that at launch
them you will be able to have your own
private world and be able to mod it and
do all of that definitely committed to
that just won't be at launch no our goal
for launch this is really new for us is
have a well running robust service
it still works great yeah it's different
there are no NPCs
let's talk about fallout 76 fall at 76
will have no NPCs no offline play no
private servers or mods at launch it
won't have a lot of things that a core
Bethesda follow game is supposed to have
and even when we do get private servers
and mods I think it's safe to assume a
solo world is gonna be pretty barren as
there wouldn't be any NPCs and the focus
of the game definitely seems to be
populating it with other players
the Thesz des wants the roles of NPCs to
be supplanted by players it shouldn't
matter whether it's a character that the
game is controlling that we
predetermined to do something and said
like oh this guy will attack the player
when it comes into this area or this guy
will trade with the person like it's up
to the players to do that so fallout 76
is not a traditional entry in the series
it is not fallout 5 it like Elder
Scrolls online is a foray of one of the
PES des IPs and do a new style of game
as I said we aren't getting fallout 5
this isn't another full installment of
Fallout this is something that the PES
des wants to work on somewhat on the
side while they make their bigger
projects like starfield
the others rose 6 so this new style of
game Fallout 76 seems to be a heavy
focus on multiplayer base building and
survival making it seem like it'll be in
the company of games like rust and arc
though I am really hesitant to say that
because it will still be filled with
fallout themes and I don't think a
strict comparison to those kinds of
games is going to be productive moving
forward in most of the world building
themes lore motifs it will still
obviously be a fallout game and while it
won't have a lot of the ways those
things were built up like through NPC's
it will still have quests and world
building through found items and
discovered locations like previous
titles yeah but there are still robots
and terminals and holotapes if you see
a lot of the quests we do in Fallout 4
that are kind of this found world yeah
quest thing we still do all of that of
the few fallout lore videos I've done a
lot of it has been not NPCs but items
and terminals and pieces of history like
that though generally was supplanted by
NBC's maybe other players will be able
to fill that role and I'm especially
hesitant to group it with other Survival
games because both Todd Howard and Pete
Hines have somewhat repeatedly stated
that they don't want Cree theme to be a
thing we don't want it to be grief II
but we want to have some drama there and
they don't want you to feel like
constantly losing your base or getting
destroyed and that is a constant theme
in those games if you've never played
rust let me tell you it's a constant
sine wave of ups and downs of having
absolutely nothing going into having a
full-fledged out based with all the gear
in the game back to nothing back to a
base back to nothing etc so it does not
seem like this Fallout game is gonna be
like that as Pete Hines and Todd Howard
have also said that it's still gonna
have RPG elements where you can build up
your character build up your stats I
don't know if we're gonna have perks but
maybe build up your perks so you won't
lose all your progress when you leave
the game I don't know how the base
building is going to work I don't know
if they're gonna let you take your base
with you when you go but if we take what
Todd and Pete said to be true then they
will have countermeasures to prevent
griefers and people from killing you
over and over and making the online
experience a terrible one
and I think we do have some reason to
believe them because obviously in the
past there has been variable amounts of
truths when they've talked about their
new upcoming games
[Music]
however with this game they're being
very upfront about the kind of game it
is how it's not a proper fallout even if
they aren't saying it's not a proper
fallout all the things they are saying
are very clear in establishing the game
as a different kind of game and they are
saying that so I think it's somewhat
justifiable to assume some truth in what
they're saying so we still have star
field and Elder Scrolls 6 before we get
the des des making another proper
fallout game and that was pretty
expected because we got Elder Scrolls
Fallout Elder Scrolls fallout so we're
not going to get fallout Elder Scrolls
I'm gonna get Elder Scrolls fallout
Elder Scrolls fallout Elder Scrolls
fallout so that means the next
mainstream Fallout game if it isn't
contracted to another studio like New
Vegas was is gonna be coming after Elder
Scrolls 6 which is probably gonna be in
like the mid 2020s which is it's quite a
ways away so because there really wasn't
any reason to expect a brand-new fully
fledged Fallout game right now we should
continue in that mindset of not
expecting a fully fledged Fallout game
it's better to view this game as what it
is Bethesda trying out a new game type
through the Fallout universe again like
Elder Scrolls online so unfortunately
the people that would only really enjoy
a traditional solo Fallout game probably
won't like this game too much and that's
totally respectable and fine if that
part of Fallout is your thing that makes
sense that you're not going to want a
survival online experience however -
what I think is going to be the majority
of people just because this game isn't a
traditional Fallout game doesn't mean
it's going to be a bad game and doesn't
mean it's something that we can't enjoy
so if you're on the fence about this
game even if you're not somebody that
only enjoys a traditional so LaFollette
game that makes total sense
and it's completely ok for you to do
that once we get some actual gameplay
shown and we get to understand the
actual mechanics of it we can continue
to form our opinions but I don't think
the fact that this isn't a traditional
soul of fall akane makes this a bad game
or something that can't be a lot of fun
especially pathetic
a really good job of this then they have
another type of game that they can make
at their disposal so we'll see at the
very least it will be an online game
with some fallout aspects which is
pretty cool they'll probably be enough
to make a couple lore videos out of it
so I'll be happy on that account
that's essentially everything I had to
say that we should give this game a
chance but not as a traditional fall
Akane not as a fully fledged flagship
title from Bethesda because it isn't
that and if we expect that we're going
to be disappointed but it might be a
pretty good game so I'm willing to wait
to see and I hope you are too
thanks for watching